il officiait depuis cinq ans à la tête
de la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique des yvelines jean
marie salanova officiellement quitté ses
fonctions le 8 avril vendredi dernier
une réception était organisée vous le
voyez en préfecture à versailles pour
son départ le préfet a souligné
l'efficacité de son action il a rappelé
la baisse significative de l'insécurité
dans le département ces dernières années
jean-marie salanova est muté au même
poste mais à marseille dans les bouches
du rhône ont beaucoup nous avons réussi
à faire baisser la délinquance
nous avons réussi à élucider beaucoup
plus d'affaires de délinquance lorsque
je suis arrivé dans ce département le
taux d'élucidation des affaires était à
32 %
jean par le taux d'élucidation des
affaires est à 41% et demi
l'organisation des services le
fonctionnement au quotidien
c'est une remise permanente de l'
ouvrage sur le métier et par voie de
conséquence je pars avec de grandes
satisfactions mais je sais que je laisse
à mes successeurs de grandes
possibilités d'amélioration encore de ce
qui a été construit